conocido como tu tercer sucio en
referencia al implacable carácter del
legendario personaje policía contra el
sucio o también conocido como el donald
trump filipino por las estridentes
declaraciones del candidato republicano
a la casa blanca el nuevo presidente de
filipinas es todo menos un político
convencional un personaje capaz de
reconocer públicamente su
responsabilidad por organizar y dirigir
escuadrones de la muerte capaz de
insultar a obama y al mismísimo papá
discutir temas de cine o de frivolizar
con la trágica violación de una
misionera australiana en este vídeo te
contamos por qué es tan popular y qué
cambios depara su mandato para filipinas
e incluso para el mundo porque amigos de
visual política esta presidencia va a
tener más implicaciones mucho más
profundas de lo que podríamos observar a
simple vista
desde el año 2010 bajo el mandato del
anterior presidente
filipinas ha registrado un crecimiento
medio del pib del 6 2% lo que ha llevado
a muchos expertos a considerar a este
país como un nuevo tigre asiático de
hecho según datos del banco mundial en
tan sólo una generación este país de más
de 100 millones de habitantes podría
dejar atrás cualquier atisbo de pobreza
sin embargo hoy por hoy las cosas son
aún muy distintas al escenario planteado
por el banco mundial
primero desempleo la delincuencia y la
pobreza son problemas generalizados está
tan francisco ha insistido en la
necesidad de luchar contra la corrupción
en un país en el que el 25 por ciento de
la población vive bajo el umbral de la
pobreza segundo es uno de los cinco
países más corruptos del sudeste
asiático y tercero padece un
interminable conflicto armado en el sur
del país con grupos yihadistas como abu
sayyaf por si no fuese suficiente en
filipinas prácticamente todo está bajo
el control de una poderosa oligarquía
diferentes estudios demuestran ojo que
tan sólo 40 familias controlan más del
75 por ciento del pib en nacional y que
apenas 178 familias casi dinastías
económicas se reparten prácticamente
todos los poderes del estado incluyendo
la jefatura de 73 de sus 80 provincias y
el 80 por ciento de los escaños del
parlamento decenas de miles de
manifestantes se reunieron en la capital
filipina
la protesta fue contra toda la clase
política dominante del país en esta
situación fuerte se presentó a las
últimas elecciones presidenciales como
un candidato ajeno a la élite y que
estaba dispuesto a luchar contra los
males que azotan el país ahora bien a
qué se debe la gran popularidad de este
personaje
el alcalde de dávao rodrigo bouterse ha
sido el alcalde de dávao la tercera
ciudad más poblada de filipinas durante
los últimos 22 años y desde luego su
gestión no ha pasado desapercibida
durante este tiempo sus excentricidades
continuas bravuconadas y salidas de tono
nos han dejado frases tan sorprendentes
y fuera de lugar como estas
no puedo imaginar la vida sin viagra
como creen que hemos pasado a ser la
novena ciudad más segura del mundo los
matamos a todos precisamente esta última
afirmación hace referencia a una de las
claves de su enorme popularidad de
vendaval por cierto este temazo que está
sonando nos la manda dos am miembro de
los all right' el un grupo de león son
había en verdad
echando un ojo a su canal os lo dejo en
la descripción en la que está su llegada
al poder era una ciudad asediada por el
crimen hoy se ha transformado en una
ciudad bastante segura pero como lo ha
conseguido aquí está el problema con
mucha mano dura y tratándose por
completo el estado de derecho aunque
resulte increíble
el propio deber te reconoce en
televisión y estar detrás de los
escuadrones de la muerte que según las
estimaciones disponibles han sido
responsables ojo de la muerte de más de
mil personas el presidente filipino
amenaza con salir de la onu es la
visceral respuesta de rodrigo duterte a
la petición de la oficina de la onu
contra la droga y el delito de que
abandone la política de asesinatos a
sospechosos de tráfico de drogas durante
los 22 años al frente de la alcaldía las
ejecuciones extrajudiciales de tráfico
antes de drogas violadores o incluso
niños de la calle se convirtieron en una
imagen recurrente además prohibió que
los menores pudieran estar en la calle a
partir de las 10 de la noche sin
acompañar un adulto a la venta y el
consumo de alcohol en establecimientos
públicos a partir de la 1 de la
madrugada y más allá de la lucha contra
el crimen el empeño por que la ciudad
estuviese limpia y la total prohibición
de fumar en público fueron otras de sus
obsesiones
pero ahora que represente de la
republica cuáles son sus intenciones
promesas electorales
prácticamente continuar con su siniestro
plan de actuación en grabado de hecho
durante la campaña electoral fue muy
criticado por su falta de propuestas o
su absoluta apatía a temas tan
importantes como la política económica
sobre la cual llegó a decir que si
limitaría a contratar a expertos
financieros para que se ocupasen de la
cuestión porque a él lo que realmente le
importa su prioridad número uno es
reducir la criminalidad en filipinas eso
sí con su estilo
durante la campaña electoral llegó a
decir que tras ser elegido daría órdenes
a la policía y al ejército de
perseguidores criminales y matarlos a
todos en el marco de un plan de choque
de seis meses de duración que podría
costar la vida a 100.000 supuestos
delincuentes
todos los síntomas drogas en serio os
voy a matar no tengo paciencia no tengo
término medio o me matáis what's matar e
idiotas estamos como veis ante un
personaje terrorífico sin la más mínima
consideración por el estado de derecho
cuantas víctimas inocentes habrá causado
una sola es demasiado acaso la solución
al crimen pasa por convertir a la
policía en una especie de mafia buscar
recompensas dónde está el límite no
dudéis ni por un instante que no se
puede luchar contra la violencia
despreciando a la justicia este tipo de
acciones al final siempre se traducen en
más violencia desde que llegó al poder
el 30 de junio de 2016 se calcula que
más de tres mil personas han perdido su
vida con su plan contra el crimen y para
reforzar esta estrategia acaba de
anunciar la implantación de la pena de
muerte ilegal en filipinas y lo que haré
es instar al congreso para que la
restauró decía y se da por ahorcamiento
otro de los puntos fuertes del programa
político de duarte consiste en
transformar el sistema político y
apostar por una intensa
descentralización el gobierno de manila
se quedará
con competencias como defensa
inmigración y aduanas mientras que las
regiones asumirán áreas como la
educación o la salud y cómo es una
persona de ideas firmes también va a
extender la prohibición de fumar en
público a todo el país hasta aquí la
política nacional pero como dijimos al
apetito del vídeo su presidencia también
entraña importantes implicaciones
internacionales
el acercamiento a china para no verte es
el protagonista de la que está haciendo
una de las más grandes derrotas de la
administración obama en el pacífico y
que significa que eeuu tendrá que
despedirse de quien hasta ahora ha sido
uno de sus más importantes aliados en la
región y es que y no poniendo en ugarte
la cercanía a washington le ha costado
muy caro a filipinas ya que ha limitado
el tráfico comercial y las inversiones
en el país de china el presidente de
filipinas rodrigo duterte ha reafirmado
durante su visita a pekín y tras su
encuentro con su homólogo chino xi
jinping su intención de separarse de su
aliado eeuu y acercarse a china por ello
no de arte ha decidido apostar fuerte
cambiar de bando e incluso plantea
exigir a estados unidos la revisión de
los acuerdos militares en vigor y la
salida de todas las tropas
estadounidenses aportadas en filipinas
sólo el tiempo nos podrá decir que hay
de bravuconada o juego táctico en este
anuncio y cuánto de realidad pero lo que
está claro es que hoy
manila mira más a pekín que a washington
en visual politics seguiremos muy de
cerca
la evolución de los acontecimientos
bueno y tú qué piensas de este personaje
comparte es nuestra apuesta por respetar
siempre el estado de derecho espero que
te haya gustado este vídeo si ha sido
así no dudes en darle a like un saludo y
hasta la próxima